(intriguing music)
- [Narrator] 362 million people
don't have internet access in China.
That's roughly 30 million more people
than the entire US population.
But this rocket holds a possible solution
to help China close the gap.
Inside it are low-Earth orbit satellites
capable of providing
high-speed internet access
even in remote areas.
In China, this technology
is still experimental
- [Controller] Ignition.
- [Narrator] But Starlink,
a subdivision of the
American company SpaceX,
has already launched 4,768 of them,
making it the leader across the globe.
Although space is vast,
these satellites operate
in a specific area that's
quickly getting more crowded.
To ensure its place, China is
building up its capabilities.
Just two decades ago,
59.1 million people in China were online,
just 4.6% of its population then.
Now, it's over 1 billion
people, 74% of the population.
So is the country known
for its rapid development,
capable of rivaling Starlink?
Of the roughly 8,000
functioning satellites
currently in orbit, about
55% belong to Starlink
and the position of its satellites is key.
For decades, satellite internet providers
relied on geostationary satellites.
These satellites are far away,
about 22,000 miles above
the Earth's surface.
That distance lets them cover a large area
and reach remote parts of the globe,
but it takes longer for data to travel
between the satellite and the user.
This means the broadband has
high latency and slower speeds.
Often, geostationary
satellites offer speeds
at least 25 megabits per second,
which is enough to stream in HD
and can support about
one to three devices.
But satellites in low-Earth
orbit or LEO, are much closer,
no more than 1,200 miles
from Earth's surface.
This means that while a LEO satellite
can't cover as much area as
a geostationary satellite,
it can provide more stable
and faster internet speeds.
Though SpaceX got its
start launching rockets,
it has built up a big
business selling broadband
powered by LEO satellites.
And a key to its success?
It owns every step of the process.
SpaceX manufactures the satellites
and launches them with its
own Falcon 9 is rockets
and Falcon 9 boosters,
the part that blasts the rocket
off the ground, are reusable
saving SpaceX money on launch costs.
- They have a very capable launch division
that is regularly blasting
satellites off for customers,
for governments, and for itself.
- [Narrator] And it can
launch dozens of satellites
into low-Earth orbit per trip.
In 2014, China opened its space sector
up to private investment.
Five years later, startups in China
received over $314 million in funding.
The only country that
attracted more startup funding
was the US.
- Ignition.
- [Narrator] In the same year,
SpaceX alone received $962 million.
To be more self-sufficient,
China has been investing in
key tech like LEO satellites.
In 2021, it established
SatNet, a state-owned company
it hopes will streamline the
process to launch satellites
and form a broadband network.
So far, China says it will
build at least 7,800 satellites.
Plus, the China Aerospace Science
and Technology Corporation
and the China Aerospace Science
and Industry Corporation
have each launched experimental satellites
into low-Earth orbit.
And startup GalaxySpace
launched several operational
satellites last year
to begin its 1,000-satellite
constellation,
but so far, no enterprise in
China has created a rocket
to launch these satellites
that's as advanced as the Falcon 9.
However, Beijing Tianbing Technology
appears to be getting closer.
While the company doesn't
have a reusable rocket yet,
it sent a liquid fuel rocket into orbit
for the first time earlier this year.
Experts say this is a crucial step
to creating a reusable rocket.
Ultimately, the company
wants to develop rockets
that can deploy up to 60
satellites in a single launch,
similar to Falcon 9's capabilities.
- It's not easy to like get
off of Earth and like deploy,
you know, hundreds or thousands
or tens of thousands of satellites
into that part of space.
You need a rocket that can,
you know, make those trips
over and over and over again.
Satellites in low-Earth
orbit have a shelf life,
they have to be replaced, so
you need to have a capability
to kind of continually launch satellites
- [Narrator] Altogether, this makes
the barrier to entry quite high.
McKinsey estimates the cost to launch
an operable constellation
is between $5 to $10 billion
with yearly operating costs
running another $1 to $2 billion.
So what's the benefit?
- The marketplace that SpaceX
has always been after is global.
- [Narrator] SpaceX said in April
that Starlink was available
in more than 50 countries,
and within the next few
years, it expects to operate
in many more countries
across Africa and Asia.
- SpaceX has been going around the world
to get permission from national regulators
to sell Starlink connections.
- [Narrator] But it's not alone.
Cooperation in space is a key part
of China's Belt and Road Initiative,
a global infrastructure project.
Last year, China said it had formed
149 space cooperation agreements
with 46 national space agencies
and already it's provided
countries across Africa,
Europe, and Asia with Beidou,
a global navigation satellite system
that rivals US-owned GPS.
Major Chinese companies
built infrastructure across the world too.
Up to 70% of 4G network
infrastructure across Africa
was built by Huawei.
- There are, you know, billions
of people around the world
that don't have have any internet at all.
Beyond that, there's like
huge demand just generally
for high-speed internet.
- [Narrator] And that demand
is part of what's driving Starlink, China
and companies everywhere
to build these LEO constellations, but-
- Satellite internet, at least right now,
faces like real cost challenges relative
to traditional on the ground
terrestrial infrastructure
for internet connections.
I don't think that like
low-Earth orbit satellites
will take over and provide
like global high-speed internet capacity.
- [Narrator] One of the biggest concerns
facing the sector's expansion
is overcrowding in low-Earth orbit.
By 2030, US officials estimate
there will be 58,000 satellites,
about a 725% increase from the
number in the sky right now.
In just the past two years,
the FCC received applications
for more than 64,000 satellites,
and experts at NASA and the FCC
fear that more satellites
could mean more issues.
Already there are over
26,000 pieces of debris,
at least the size of a
softball in low-Earth orbit
that could destroy a satellite on impact.
- If you assume that
like tens of thousands
of additional satellites
are launched and deployed
to low-Earth orbit in the coming years,
there's gonna be a real need
for coordination communication,
finding ways for all these operators
to sort of know where
their devices are located,
how they're moving and what
like the potential threat
is for a collision.
Low-Earth orbit, it's sort
of like a commons right now.
There's some treaties that
govern space and there are also
what experts and government
officials call norms
around good space behavior.
It's a little more
open-ended and dependent
on actors there to sort of
work together and communicate.
(intriguing music)